大家好，我是 Rio，在 Cursor 做设计。这是我今天的演讲：《更贴近材料：AI 如何改变我们构建软件的方式，以及它绝不能抹掉什么》。我希望这样的东西早就存在。这场演讲是在 Rio OS 里写出来的，Rio OS 是我用 Cursor 搭出来的一个小型计算环境。
我做它，是因为我怀念一种感觉：电脑曾经像一个开放的游乐场，而不只是一个个孤立的应用，也不只是命令行提示符。它应该是一个可以让我 tinkering、让我思考的地方。很长一段时间里，这都只是卡在我脑子里的一个想法，一条笔记，一个草图。有时我会把这些想法讲给朋友听，但它们从来没有真正变成现实。可现在，循环变了。
我可以先做出其中一小块，玩一玩，发现哪里不对。然后我可以让 Cursor 重塑它，让整个东西演化，调整某一个细节，再试一次，一次又一次。最后，RealOS 不再只是一个 vibe-coded 的音效板应用。它变成了一个我可以在里面思考的地方。它有我的灵魂。这就是为什么我觉得此刻真的不一样。
AI 正在压缩想法和现实之间的距离，压缩“希望某个东西存在”和“让它的一部分真实存在”之间的距离。你可以输入一句话，然后看它活过来。你可以让一个智能体读取整个代码库，制定计划，调度更多智能体，验证正确性，并不断循环。
这非常惊人。但它也让一个老问题变得更尖锐。因为当更多东西可以被更多智能体更快地构建出来时，问题就不再只是“我们能不能做”。问题变成了：“什么东西应该存在？”更私人一点地说，这个工具是让我更接近真实，还是把我推得更远？
这就是我想聊的：AI 如何改变我们构建东西的方式，以及它绝不能抹掉什么。AI 改变的最重要的东西，是循环。过去，做软件是一个很慢的循环。你有一个想法，把它翻译成规格文档；设计师做设计，工程师实现，产品经理评审，QA 测试，然后大家进入下一件事。
这个循环很昂贵，所以我们会保护它。我们会在动手之前争论，在接触材料之前规划。我们试图提前做对，因为做错的代价很高。但现在，这个循环快得多了。
你可以有一个想法，要求生成一个版本，检查结果，修改它，运行它，然后继续。有时只需要几分钟，有时甚至几秒。这不只是生产力变化，它改变了判断力形成的方式，因为第一个版本几乎从来都不是对的。
概念太模糊，转场感觉卡顿，间距在技术上正确，但视觉上不对。文案说的是正确的话，却不是真正该说的话。只有当它存在之后，你才会注意到这些。然后你修改它。那个小小的修正，就是判断力形成的地方。你尝试一些东西，世界给你反馈，你注意到哪里不对，再调整，于是建立直觉。
这个循环，就是品味形成的地方。它也是手艺生长的地方，是你变得更擅长这件事的地方。所以 AI 的承诺，不只是让我们更快做出更多东西。
更深层的承诺是，它可以让更多人进入这个循环，并且进入到他们想要的深度。设计师可以更接近实现，工程师可以探索不同架构方向，那些从不认为自己是程序员的人，也可以做出自己想象中某个东西的第一个版本。
这是好的部分，也是我真正关心的部分。但随着循环变快，它也可能被隐藏起来。一旦循环被隐藏，人们就不再从中学习。工具变成黑盒。你许一个愿，等待，然后得到一个输出。
如果它能用，你并不真正知道为什么；如果它失败，你也不知道问题出在哪里。如果它改变了你的工作方式，你甚至可能没有意识到自己身上发生了什么变化。这不是构建，这是在拉老虎机。循环很重要，因为它让你保持清醒，迫使你注意，要求你在乎。
如果 AI 让执行变便宜，却让判断变弱，那我们得到的不是文艺复兴，而是带着可用按钮的垃圾。这就是当下非常奇怪的地方：两件事同时为真。更多人可以构建，更多平庸的东西也会被构建。更多代码被写出来，更多原型出现，更多功能上线，但投入到决策里的注意力可能变少。
什么应该存在？为什么它应该存在？什么应该被拒绝？哪里应该慢下来？当制造东西几乎不花成本时，平庸的东西并不总是看起来很糟。它们看起来还行，能工作，能上线，能填满空间。
现在这样的东西可能会无限多。能运转但没有意义的软件，正确但没有生命的界面，由智能体制造、却没有任何人真正承担的产品，被发往虚空。对我来说，这是真实风险。不是机器变得太有创造力，而是人类在机器周围变得太被动。危险的版本其实非常舒服。
你许一个愿，机器消失，然后带着一个看似合理的东西回来。按钮能点，页面能渲染，演示能通过，但你从来没有进入决策内部。你只是批准了表面。危险不在于更多人能做软件，那是好事。危险在于界面把人变成审批者。危险在于我们把输出误认为材料。
输出会结束循环，材料会邀请你回到循环里。输出说：答案在这里。材料说：来触碰它，塑造它，让它成为你的东西。这个区别非常重要，因为制造不只是生产一个产物，制造本身是一种思考方式。如果 AI 把过程隐藏得太多，它仍然可以给你输出，但它会拿走那些让你变强的挣扎。
我不喜欢那个未来。我不想要软件自己构建，而人类只是在旁边观看。那会是一个无聊的未来。我想要的工具，是让人更贴近材料。所以我加入 Cursor，是因为我非常切身地感受到这个问题。我觉得 Cursor 和代码可以帮助更多人。
不是把每个人都变成程序员，而是让工具足够灵活，可以从最简单的需求一直延展到最专业的使用。Cursor 继承了很多 VS Code 的东西，这是巨大优势。它给了我们成熟的编辑器、强大的前提，以及快速前进的方式。但围绕这个基础的世界变化得非常快。
模型变强了，智能体更有能力了，交互的形态也开始变化。突然之间，问题不再是：我们怎么给代码编辑器加 AI？问题变成了：
如果今天要在一个智能体的世界里设计一个软件环境，它应该是什么感觉？不只是挂在 IDE 旁边的聊天面板，不只是自动补全，不只是一个 AI 给你答案的地方。它应该是一个人类和智能体能在同一份材料里一起工作的地方。这就是我们新界面背后的动机，我们内部叫它 Glass。
当我说 Glass 时，我不是在说一种视觉风格，不是 backdrop filter blur，也不是 liquid glass。我说的是一种界面原则：系统应该让你看穿它的工作。不是因为你想控制一切，而是因为有时候，一个很小的细节就能告诉你整个东西对不对。
在黑盒里，AI 消失，然后带回一个结论。在 Glass 里，AI 按照你想看的方式工作。你能看到计划，看到思考和工具调用流进来，看到改动，看到命令运行。你可以停止它，可以塑造它，可以更深地检查，也可以接管。你不必读每一行，但你永远可以读。这个选择很重要。对有经验的程序员来说，这意味着他们可以让智能体流动起来，在需要时跳进去。
对设计师来说，这意味着他们可以接受结构，同时调整一个让它感觉正确的小细节。对新程序员来说，这意味着他们可以慢下来，阅读计划，并通过观察来学习。同一个系统应该支持这三种人。渐进式披露，无限深度。选择权应该在用户手里，而不是我们手里。随着 AI 变得更强，这一点会越来越重要。
当智能体工作几分钟时，你需要能转向；当智能体工作几个小时时，你需要整个系统是可读的。你需要知道发生了什么，需要检查状态，需要设计护栏，需要表达你想要什么。
如果一切都被隐藏，你只是在许愿。而许愿不是一个好界面。没有可见性的能力，并不真正是工具，而是一种风险。所以答案不是拒绝自动化，那很蠢；答案也不是永远手动参与每一个小步骤，那会让人筋疲力尽。
关键是选择。你应该能从机器里退出来，让它承载工作；也应该能在最关键的地方重新踏进去。因为有些决策不只是任务，它们是你的品味进入材料的地方。
是你的价值观变得可见的地方，是那个东西开始感觉像是“来自某个人”的地方。黑盒优化的是干净输出，Glass 优化的是人的能动性。黑盒把软件简化成一个愿望和一个裁决，Glass 把软件变成粘土。
Glass 维护的是贴近材料的权利。今年一月，我们开始探索这个想法，想对 Cursor 界面做一次更激进的重置。内部一开始叫 baby cursor 3，是一个基于 Cursor CLI 的 Electron 原型。重点不是重建完整的生产架构，而是创造一个能让我们亲手思考的环境。
没有 VS Code 那套包袱，一个快速、灵活的游乐场，让我们可以同时探索大的结构变化和小的交互机制。当一个界面要服务于从一个到多个智能体、从零到一再到多个项目时，它应该是什么感觉？默认应该显示多少状态？在不同概念和作用域之间导航是什么感觉？它是否足够简单，同时又能为在乎的人揭示更深路径？
这些问题不能只靠文档或 Figma mock 来回答。你必须感受它。你必须构建一个东西，使用它，发现哪里不对，然后修改它。因为我们是用 Cursor 来构建 Cursor，这个循环变得紧密得多：想法、原型、反应、编辑、重复。速度本身不是最有意思的地方，真正酷的是，更快的原型帮助我们形成确信。
我们不再只是通过文档和观点来对齐，而是可以通过 demo 看见。我们不再试图从远处预测产品，而是通过构建来发现它。到某个时刻，原型不再只是实验，我们让它成为真实。然后 baby cursor 发展成了 baby glass。
Baby Glass 是我们新的原型环境。它变成了一个网页应用，这件事很重要，因为分享变得更容易。团队里更多人可以在同一个游乐场里工作。原型不再像私人沙箱，而更像一个共享的、用来思考未来的环境。
这就是我希望 AI 工具创造的循环：不只是更快的输出，而是更快地接触材料，更快地学习，更快地产生分歧，更快地协作，更快地形成确信。因为最好的想法并不是一开始就完整成形，它们是在你足够贴近时，才逐渐清晰地显露出自己想变成什么。所以，如果智能体能执行更多循环，那留给我们的是什么？
我认为答案在循环之前和之后。
在循环之前，有那个让你开始的东西。一个你无法忽视的摩擦，一个让你不舒服的缺口，一种“某个东西应该存在”的感觉，哪怕你还说不清它。我有这种感觉很久了。曾经有一段时间，使用 Mac 像是在触碰一个活物。等一下这个人。第一，我们想给专业用户一个更强大的用户界面。
但第二，在同一时间，我们也希望这个界面成为那些从没碰过电脑的人梦寐以求的界面。曾经，使用 Mac 真的像触碰活物。Dock 会弹跳，神灯效果会飞出来，Expose 会把窗口像桌上的车一样散开。
这些都不是必需的，但它们都让人感觉有人在乎。软件有质感，有观点，你能感受到背后的人。后来，不知从什么时候开始，很多软件变得更平滑、更快速、更一致，却也更无趣。那些怪癖被移除了，因为测试结果不好；那些温暖被砍掉了，因为无法度量。
我们优化出一个东西完美运转、但感觉什么都不是的世界。现在 AI 又让速度变得非人类。你可以一个下午生成一个完整产品，午饭前上线一个功能，喝咖啡前做出十个想法变体。这很疯狂，但问题仍然一样：当制造东西几乎不花成本时，垃圾也变成免费的。
这就是为什么人类更重要，而不是更不重要。品味不是提示词，关心不是参数。你放进某个东西里的那种奇怪、具体、个人化的东西，无法通过平均值生成出来。在 Notion 时，我以一种方式在乎这件事。人们不需要另一个单一用途应用，他们需要的是简单原语，可以长成他们工作的形状。
在 Cursor，我以另一种方式在乎它。人们不只是需要能生产代码的 AI，他们需要一个环境，让他们仍然是自己工作的作者。RealOS 也来自同一种本能，只是更个人化。
我怀念电脑像地方一样的感觉。我怀念有质感、有历史、有玩心、还有一点怪的软件。我想看看，如果一个 AI 系统不是住在聊天框里，而是住在一个环境里，会发生什么。
如果文件、应用、音乐、笔记、地图、设置、记忆、智能体全都是一个东西，会怎样？如果 demo 不是一张讲“软件变成粘土”的幻灯片，而 demo 本身就是那块粘土，会怎样？最初的那种痒，不是智能体能替你生成的。它必须来自你生活在世界里，并注意到哪里不对。循环之后，则是责任。
我们把什么发布到了世界上？它改变了什么？它服务了谁？它让什么东西更容易发生？
智能体可以执行循环，可以放大循环，可以做十个版本、一百个版本、一千个版本。但它们不知道什么值得保护。它们不知道某个东西虽然技术上正确，却感觉死气沉沉。它们不知道一个东西正在悄悄把我们拉向怎样的未来。这仍然是我们的责任。手艺不会消失，它会移动。当执行很昂贵时，手艺存在于执行本身。
那一行小心写下的代码，那一个精确的布局，那句改了十二遍的小文案。这些仍然重要。但当生成变便宜时，手艺会向上游和下游移动。向上游移动到判断：问什么、保留什么、拒绝什么、在哪里慢下来、什么不该做。向下游移动到责任。
我们发布了什么？它改变了什么？它服务了谁？制造不只是生产一个产物，而是在下注：世界应该存在什么样的东西。手艺不会消失，它会移动到判断的边缘。这场演讲从 RealOS 里的一条小笔记开始，从一种“某个东西应该存在”的感觉开始。到现在，这条笔记已经变了。
不是因为这个想法变得完美，而是因为它变得真实。我可以做出一小块，使用它，感受哪里不对，调整某个细节，一次又一次地尝试。到某个时刻，这个东西不再只是一个想法。它变成了一个我可以在里面思考的地方。我可以用这个东西来思考这个东西本身。
这就是我为什么构建东西的时刻。不是为了生产力，不是为了颠覆，也不是为了什么宏大的词。那个时刻，是某个原本只存在于你脑子里的东西，变得足够真实，可以让别人看见和触摸。
这一点没有变，也不会变。工具会变，模型会变，经济性会变，但这部分会留下来。你感觉某个地方不对，于是做下一个标记。世界回应你，你让它变得真实。最后，那个东西真实到可以触碰到别人。这就是我想要的未来。不是软件自己构建，而人类只在旁边观看。
我想做的是让人更贴近材料的工具。让想象和现实之间的循环更短、更清楚、更诚实。帮助人们留在工作里，不是作为被动审批者，而是作为作者。因为 AI 的意义不是让人类消失，而是让更多人感受到一开始驱动这一切的那种感觉。
我感觉这个东西应该存在，而且我可以把它变成现实。如果我们做对了，未来就不只是更快，也会更有人味。谢谢。